The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Happy Valentine's
Day 11.
Actually, maybe it's a
little smiley face
combined with an 11.
Did any of you leave
this here for me?
Or am I just stroking
my ego and this was
left for someone yesterday?
Stroking my ego, all right.
OK, last lecture, we looked at
a program for finding roots
and put in a little debugging
statement that, along the way,
printed various approximations
to the root.
Now, suppose that instead of
printing things, we actually
wanted to collect the
approximations.
For example, to be able to go
back and look at them later
and analyze them, do various
kinds of things.
To do this, and this is the sort
of thing we do a lot, we
need some data structures that
can be used for amassing
collections of items.
There are 3 data structures
in Python that are used to
collect items.
I'm going to try and cover
all of them today.
Tuples, lists, and
dictionaries.
We'll start with tuples
and lists.
And what they have in common is
they are ordered sequences
of objects.
So the key notion here
is they're ordered.
It makes sense to talk about the
first object, the second
object, the last object,
et cetera.
When we get to dictionaries, or
dicts as they're spelled in
Python, we'll see that
they're not ordered.
All right, let's look
at tuples first.
They're the simplest.
So if we look at it, there's
a very simple
example at the top.
I have this tuple called test.
And I just said that's
the sequence of
ints 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
I can then index into it.
For example, look at
the first element,
which is the 0th element.
Or I could look at
the next element.
And we can print them.
So let's just do that.
And you can see it prints 1
and 2, not surprisingly.
I can print the whole
thing if I want.
That lets me look at
the entire tuple.
I can also look at this.
And that gives me the last
element without my having to
know what the last element is.
I can ask about the
length of a tuple.
And it tells me it's five.
Similarly, I could write
something like this.
Print test.
Why was that out of range?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because you're
indexing from 0?
PROFESSOR: Because I'm
indexing from 0.
So that's why I have this
more convenient way of
writing minus 1.
Otherwise, I'd have to
do len minus one.
Good grab.
OK, let's look at a little
example of how we might use
this sort of thing.
So here, I've just written a
little piece of code that
finds divisors.
Going to find all of the divisor
of 100, collect them
into a tuple.
Notice this kind of funny piece
of syntax here, i comma.
I need to do that to say it's
a tuple of length one.
Why can't I just write open
paren, i, comma, open paren?
Because that would just take
the expression, i, and
parenthesize it as we often use
parentheses for grouping
when we write things.
So by inserting this comma, I
say, I don't just mean the--
in this case-- say
the number i.
I mean the tuple
of length one.
So it's sort of a special case
piece of syntax that you need
for tuples of length one.
Then, I can print
the divisors.
So let's run that.
And it now prints the
tuple for me.
So I've run through.
I've computed all
the divisors.
And I've collected them.
Nothing very interesting,
but kind of useful.
We can also--
I've shown you how to select
elements of tuples.
I can also, if I choose,
get what are
called slices of tuples.
So a slice gives me a range of
values, or in this case, a
subsequence of the tuple.
As we'll see, we can
also slice lists.
So let's see.
We have a tuple called
divisors here.
Yeah, OK, I'll save
the source.
Oh, come on!
So if I wanted to do--
what did I call it?
I called it divisors.
So I can do something
like divisors 1:3.
And you'll note that gives me
those two elements at the
appropriate places.
And so it's a very convenient
way to take pieces of it.
All right, any questions
about tuples?
Not very deep.
Lists are, I think, more useful
than tuples and also,
alas, more complicated.
And they're complicated because
the big difference is
that tuples are immutable.
And by that, I mean once you've
created a tuple, you
cannot change its value.
You can create a new tuple.
but you can't change the
value of the old tuple.
In contrast, lists
are mutable.
Once you've created a list, you
can actually change it.
It's the first mutable type
we've looked at because you'll
recall assignment didn't
actually change
the value of an object.
It just changed the object to
which an identifier was bound.
Mutability is the first time
we've seen a way to actually
change the value of
an object itself.
And that's, as we'll see, both
a powerful concept and an
opportunity to mess yourself
up by committing serious
programming blunders.
All right, so let's look at an
example here, first of many
we'll be looking at.
So first, we won't worry too
much about the mutability.
So here, I'm creating a list
called techs, which happens to
be, in this case, a
list of strings.
Lists need not be homogeneous.
As we'll see, you can mix
strings, and floats, and ints.
And most interestingly, you
can have lists of list.
And then, another list
called ivies.
And then, I'm going to say I'm
going to have these univs, yet
another list.
This list empty, containing
no elements.
Then, I'm going to append
techs to ivies.
Notice this syntax--
univs.append.
What that means here is
that append is what
Python calls a method.
As we'll see when we get to
classes, methods play a very
important role in Python.
But to a first approximation,
it's quite safe to think of a
method as an alternative syntax
for writing function.
So instead of writing something
like append a list
and an element, I write
l.append the element.
And just think of this l over
here as a fancy way of
denoting the first argument to
the function append, the first
actual parameter.
When we get to classes in a few
weeks, we'll see why it's
highly useful to have this
specialized syntax.
But for now, just think of it as
a piece of syntactic sugar,
if you will.
The thing I want you to think
about, though, is this is not
equivalent to assigning
something to l.
This actually mutates
the list.
And we say it has
a side effect.
Up till now, since we've only
been dealing with immutable
types, every function we've
looked at, its job was to take
in a bunch of values, do some
computation, return a value.
It didn't change anything.
And then, if we wanted to take
advantage of what the function
did, we had to assign the value
it returned to some
variable, and then we
could manipulate it.
Or we could print the
value it returned.
We had to do something with
the value it returned.
Here, we invoke append.
And rather than worrying about
what it returns, we're
invoking it for the purpose
of its side effect--
the modification it performs
on the list.
So let's look at what we
get when we run this.
So you'll notice what
univs is now.
It's a list of length one.
And the one element in it is
itself a list because I have
appended a list to the end
of the empty list--
not the elements of the list,
but the list itself, OK?
So it's important to notice the
difference between a list
that contained the elements MIT
and Cal Tech, and a list
that contained a list
which contains the
elements MIT and Cal Tech.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Previously, you added
two tuples together.
And that's not like
appending, right?
PROFESSOR: Because when I
concatenated two tuples, in
order to do something useful
with that value, I had to
assign it to something.
It did not modify anything.
It produced a new tuple
which was the value
of appending them.
And then, it assigned
it to a new tuple.
So it's quite different from
append, which is actually
having a side effect
on the list.
Does not produce a new list,
it modifies the old list.
So we can look at this, draw
a little picture here.
So we had techs.
And that pointed to a list with
two elements in it, which
I'll abbreviated as
MIT and Cal Tech.
Both of these elements
were strings.
Then, I created a new
list called univs.
And that was initially bound to
the empty list, a list with
no elements in it.
I then did an append.
And the effect of the
append was to modify
univs so that it pointed--
now, I had one element.
And the element it was
was this list.
Notice it didn't
copy this list.
It actually included
the list itself.
So let's look at the
ramifications of
doing it that way.
Whoops.
So what I'm going to do
now is append another
element called ivies.
I'm going to then print it.
And then, for e in univs-- so
here's kind of a nice thing
you can do with lists.
You can iterate over the
elements in the list.
So you might think that the way
to do that is, well, I'll
go for i index in range
0 to length of list.
That would be equivalent.
But it's, in fact, much easier
to just write this way--
for e in univs.
That will do something to every
element of the list.
I'm going to print what
the element is.
So let's look at that.
So now, I have a list, as we
see here, of length two.
It contains two lists.
And if I print the elements, I
print each of those lists.
Nothing very magical there.
Now, suppose I wanted
it flattened.
You asked the question about
the tuples where I did
concatenation.
Well, I can do the
same thing here.
I'll let flat equal
techs plus ivies.
And then, I'll print flat.
And you'll note here what
concatenation does is it just
takes the elements of the list
and creates a new list and
appends it.
Not append it-- in this
case, it assigns it to
flat, excuse me.
So that's convenient.
Poor old plus is overloaded
with yet another meaning.
All right, let's keep
on trucking.
I, of course, can
do this myself.
So here, I've got another
list called artSchools.
It includes RISD and Harvard.
For u2 in artSchools, if u2 in
flat, I'm going to remove it.
All right, so again, I'm going
to iterate over everything in
artSchools.
What's this going to
do, do you think?
What will I get when
I print it here?
No new concepts here.
This is all stuff we've seen.
Somebody up there?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Flat without
Harvard in it?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The correct answer was flat
without Harvard in it.
Wow, almost a good catch.
Just almost there.
All right, so let's confirm.
Yes, we'll save it.
Thank you.
All right, so we've now removed
the art school.
All right, we'll look
at one more thing.
Actually, we'll look at far
more than one more thing.
But we'll look at one more
thing for the moment.
So I'm going to invoke
another method.
This is a built-in method
of Python that
works on sequence types.
And it's called sort.
So you can do-- this will have
a side effect on flat.
And it will, as you might guess,
put them in order.
So let's run that.
Actually, we'll comment this
out for the moment.
So you'll now note that
it's put them in
alphabetical order.
This is something, again, that
you'll find convenient
throughout the term, the ability
to have the side
effect of sorting a list.
Now, I'm going to assign
something to flat sub 1.
So let's think about what this
is going to be doing.
It's going to replace
the first element of
flat by a new value.
So it's having, again, a
side effect on flat.
So you have to be a little bit
careful as you think about
this, that I've written
something that looks like a
conventional assignment
statement.
But in fact, flat sub 1
is not an identifier.
So this is not binding the name,
flat sub 1, To UMass.
It's actually modifying the
object that is the first
element of flat.
AUDIENCE: So would an identifier
just be a name,
flat, for example?
PROFESSOR: Well, I
think the way--
the question is, would the
identifier just be "flat?" No.
Don't think of this as
an assignment at all.
Because remember, what an
assignment does is swing one
of these pointers to point
to a different object.
We'll see an example of that.
Whereas here, I'm actually
modifying a piece of the
object that the identifier
points to.
So it's not an assignment in
the sense of a re-binding.
It's actually having
a side effect of
modifying the object.
Let's just run it.
And then, I'll be happy
with the question.
So here, you'll see I changed
flat sub 1 to now be UMass.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: As you've drawn on
the blackboard here, you've
drawn an arrow to the actual
object that's techs.
So if we change techs,
will we change univs?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The question was if we change
techs, will we change univs?
Now, in some sense, that's
a philosophical question.
From the philosophical
point of view, maybe,
you could say no.
Univs is still the
same object.
So the binding has
not been changed.
But the object to which it has
been bound is now different.
Same object, but it has a
new value, all right?
So this is the key thing
to keep in mind.
Assignment has to do with the
binding of names to objects.
Mutation has to do with changing
the value of objects.
We'll see that pretty
graphically in the next
example that I wanted to
work my way through.
So I'm going to work through
a dull example.
But I think it illustrates
the points.
And I do, by the way, very much
appreciate the questions,
even if I forget to throw you
candy in return for asking.
But it's good.
If you have questions,
please do ask them.
And I'll try and remember
to feed you.
So let's work through what
this code is going to do.
So first, I'm going to
have the list L1.
So the first thing, I'm going to
create an object which is a
list of length one containing
the integer 2.
So L1 will be bound to the
list of length one
containing the int 2.
I'm then going to create another
list, L2, which is
going to be of length two.
And the first element
will be L1.
And the second element
So what will happen
if I print L2?
What will I get?
I'll get list two, comma,
list two, right?
We can look at it.
If I print L2, excuse me.
All right, just what we
would have expected.
Now, I'm going to change the
0th value of L1 to be 3.
So I'm going to mutate L1.
Now, if I print L2, I will get
a different value, 3, 3.
Not surprising.
It's something to keep in mind
that can be useful, but can
also be confusing.
Because if I'm looking at my
code, it doesn't look like I
changed L2 when I have
a side effect on L1.
And so it can be mystifying when
you're trying to debug.
You print L2.
You do a bunch of--
execute a bunch of statements,
none of which
apparently deals with L2.
Then, you print L2 again and
get a different value.
This is both the beauty and
the peril of mutation.
Now, let's see what this does.
So here, I've now mutated L2 so
that its first element is
no longer the list, L1, but
is now the string a.
And we'll just do a bunch of
these all at once here.
Now, I'm going to change
L1 to be 2, length one.
So what do you think will
happen, by the way, if, after
this, I print L2?
Whoops.
What do you think is going
to get printed here?
This is important.
You need to figure this out.
What's going to get
printed here?
A volunteer, please.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: it's going to print
"a" in the first slot and then
L1 in the second slot.
PROFESSOR: Well--
AUDIENCE: So it's "a"
and then "2."
PROFESSOR: "a" and then
"2" is one conjecture.
Let's find out.
"a" and then "3." Why?
Because what happened here is,
when I did the assignment to
L1, what that effectively did
was swing this pointer to
point to the new list containing
the element 2, but
had no effect on this object.
I was changing the binding
of the identifier.
I was not mutating
this object.
And so this element still points
to the same list, which
was not mutated.
That makes sense now?
So you have to get your
head around the way
all this stuff works.
Anybody have a question about
why this is what it did?
All right, if not, we'll
just roar right along.
So now, we can do
various things.
And we'll get some stuff.
All right, moving right along.
Here's an interesting little
program not in your hand out.
Let me get rid of
all this cruft.
So here's a function,
copylist.
It takes a source list and
a destination list.
And for e in the source list, it
appends it to whatever the
destination list used to be.
And then, I'm just putting in
a little print statement so
we'll be able to see as it
runs what it's doing.
So I'm going to say L1 is
equal to the empty list.
L2 is 1, 2, 3.
And I'm going to copylist
L2 to L1.
Print L1 and L2.
So what am I going to get when
I print those things?
This is the easy question.
Don't tell me I have you
so intimidated that
you think I'm playing.
This is not a trick question.
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: 1, 2, 3 for
both of them?
PROFESSOR: 1, 2, 3
for both of them.
Who said that?
Raise your hand.
Someone back--
oh, good grief, all the
way in the back.
All right.
Oh no, not even close!
Off by a row, and about
four people, too.
OK.
so let's try it.
1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3.
So exactly as predicted.
Now comes the trick question.
What is this going to do?
Pardon?
Well, we'll print L1 here.
What do you think it'll
do when it gets
to that print statement?
Will it get to that
print statement?
Let me ask that question.
Will it ever get there?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Bingo.
Let's run it.
And you'll see LDest just gets
longer and longer and longer.
Why is that happening?
Because what it's attempting to
do is look at LSource and
copy the remaining elements
of LSource to LDest.
But every time I go through the
loop, what we have is a
situation where the formal
LSource and LDest are now
pointing to the same object.
So every time I modify LDest,
I am modifying the object to
which LSource points to.
And I keep finding yet another
thing to copy.
This is an example of what's
called an alias, one object
with two names, or in general
multiple names.
When you have immutable
objects, aliasing
is perfectly harmless.
If you have 58 different names
for the object 3, it doesn't
matter because you can never
change what 3 means.
Here, where you have multiple
names for the same mutable
object, you can get massive
confusion when you modify it
through one name and then
forget that it's being
accessed through another.
So it's something
to worry about.
As with tuples, you
can slice lists.
You can index into lists.
You can concatenate lists.
You can do all the
usual things.
I'm not going to list all
of the operators.
And there are a lot of
very nice operators.
But we'll post readings where
you can find what operators
are available.
I now want to move on to the
third built-in type that
collects values, and that's
a dictionary.
A dictionary differs from
a list in two ways.
One, the elements
are not ordered.
And two, more profoundly, the
indices need not be integers.
And they're not called
indices.
They're called keys.
They can be any immutable
type.
So we'll look at a simple
example first.
So here, I'm creating
a new dict.
We use set braces rather than
square braces to remind
ourselves that the elements
are not ordered.
And I'm saying the first
key is the number 1.
And that's bound to the string
object "1, 1." And then the
second key is the string object
deux, which is bound to
the string object 2.
And the third one is the string
object pi which is
bound to the float 3.14159.
Now I can then index into it.
So for example, if I choose to,
I can write something like
print d sub pi.
I'll just stop it here with my
old trick of asserting false.
And you'll see it will
print the value with
which the key is bound--
to which the key is bound.
So what we have here is a dict
is a set of key value pairs.
And I can access it by
looking at the keys.
I can do an assignment,
d1 equals d, just
as I can with lists.
And now, I remember this
is a real assignment.
So now, I have an alias,
two identifiers
pointing to the same dict.
I can then print d1 sub 1,
either print it or I could
assign to it.
So let's do that.
First, we'll print it just
to show what we get.
Then, I'm going to do an
assignment, saying, OK, I want
to now change the binding in
d of the key one to be uno
rather than one.
And we'll get something
different.
Let's just run this.
So you'll note, as we would have
guessed, with mutability,
we see it showing up.
So far, just like lists, the
difference being we have key
value pairs rather than you
could think of a list as being
int value pairs.
The indices of a list
are always ints.
Associated with each of those
ints, we have a value.
Let's look at a more fun example
showing what we can do
with dictionaries.
So here, I have a very simple
dictionary called EtoF, for
English to French.
And we can do some
things with it.
So I can print it.
And that's kind of
interesting.
Let's see what we get
when we print it.
So it's printing it.
And you'll notice the order in
which it's printed, the key
value pairs, is not the order
in which I typed them.
That's OK.
The order in which it prints
them is not defined by Python.
So there's no way to
predict the order.
And that makes sense because, by
specification, dictionaries
are unordered.
They're sets, not sequences.
I can print keys, EtoF
keys, open, close.
Keys is a method on dicts
that returns the keys.
And then, just for fun, I'm
going to try to print
EtoF.keys without
the open, close.
So you'll see when I first
printed it with the open,
closed, I got all of the keys
in an order that was not
necessarily predictable.
Certainly not the order
in which I typed them.
But that's nice.
I now have this sequence
of keys that I
could do things with.
When I typed it without the
open, close, and I wanted you
to see this, it just says it's
a method, a built-in method.
It does not execute
the method, right?
That's fine.
But again, you have to be
careful that you'll find this
happening when you write code.
You'll forget to write
the open, close.
And you'll wonder why your
program isn't doing what you
expect it to do.
Remember, it's not saying
that the method,
keys, has no argument.
It has one argument.
In this case, EtoF.
And the open, close is basically
saying, all right,
call the method rather than
the method itself.
Again, this will be
very important
when we get to classes.
Let's get rid of some of these
print statements now.
Suppose I want to delete
something.
I can delete something, so
delete EtoF sub 1 del is a
command, much like print,
that says remove
something from EtoF.
So I can do that.
And now, something
has disappeared.
The key value pair where
the key is one is gone.
So that's how I remove things.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are the keys of
dictionaries mutable?
PROFESSOR: The keys have
to be immutable.
You cannot use a mutable
type for a key.
We'll see the reason for that in
a couple of lectures when I
talk about how dictionaries
are implemented in Python.
They use a very clever technique
called hashing which
would not work if the
keys were mutable.
So in order to get an efficient
implementation of
dictionary look-up, we need
to have immutable keys.
And so that's required.
Let's look at another example.
So here, I'm again setting
a dictionary.
And now, what I'm going to show
you is that I can iterate
through the keys and
print the values.
For key in d1.keys, nothing
very fancy here.
OK?
one equals uno, pi equals
3.1459, and deux equals 2.
All right?
So nothing very dramatic
happening here.
Finally, just to illustrate
why this sort of thing is
particularly useful.
And in fact, you'll find it
quite useful in the upcoming
problem set.
I'm going to do some
translations.
This, by the way, is not the
way Google Translate works.
It's a bit more sophisticated.
So I'm going to have two
functions, translateword,
which, if it finds the word in
the dictionary, returns the
value associated with the key.
So note, if word in dictionary
says is there a key whose
value is word?
If so, return the value
associated with that key.
Otherwise, don't even try
and translate it.
Just leave it the way it was.
And then, translatesentence will
set the translation equal
to the empty string
and wordequals
to the empty string.
Then, it'll just collect all the
characters until it finds
a blank, translate
the word using
translateword, and append it.
And when it's done,
it will print it.
So we can now do these
translations quite simply.
What could be easier?
You never again have to learn
a foreign language.
Just use Python to do the
translations for you.
All right, that's
it for today.
Remember, there is a problem set
you should be working on
and another one that
will be posted.
Take care.